there's
very few things as entertaining as
watching either evolution computation or
reinforcement learning teaching a
simulated robot to walk
i maybe there's a higher level question
that could be asked here
but do you find this whole space in of
applications in the robotics
interesting for evolution computation
yeah yeah very much
um and indeed that's there are
fascinating videos of that
and that's actually one of the examples
where you can contrast the difference
so between reinforcement learning
evolution yes so
if you have a reinforcement learning
agent it tries to be conservative
because it wants to walk as long as
possible and be stable
but if you have evolutionary computation
it can afford
these agents that go haywire they
fall flat on their face and they could
take a step and then they jump and they
again fall flat
yeah and eventually what comes out of
that is something like a
falling that's controlled yeah and you
take another step another step and you
no longer
fall instead you run you go fast so
that's a way of discovering
something that's hard to discover step
by step incrementally
because you can afford these um
evolutionist
dead ends although they are not entirely
dead ends in the sense that they can
serve as stepping stones
when you take two of those put them
together you get something that works
even better
and that is a great example of uh of
this kind of discovery
yeah learning to walk is a is
fascinating i talked quite a bit to russ
dedrick because mit
there's a there's a community of folks
who who just roboticists who love the
elegance
and beauty of movement right
and of walking bipedal
robotics is um
beautiful but also exceptionally
dangerous in the sense that like
you're constantly falling essentially if
you want to do elegant movement
and uh the discovery of that is uh
i mean it's such a good example of um
that the discovery of a good solution
sometimes requires a leap of faith and
patience and all those kinds of things
i wonder what other spaces where you
have to discover those kinds of things
in
yeah yeah and another interesting
direction is um
learning um for for uh virtual creatures
learning to walk
uh we did a study in in simulation
obviously that
um you create those creatures not just
their controller but also their body so
you have
cylinders you have muscles you have
joints
and sensors and you're creating
creatures that look quite different some
of them have multiple legs some of them
have no legs at all
and then the goal was to get them to
move the walk to run
and what was interesting is is that when
you evolve
the controller together with the body
you get movements that look natural
because they're optimized for that
physical setup
and and these creatures you start
believing them that they're alive
because they walk in a way that you
would expect somebody
with that kind of a setup to walk
you